I guess the big trending thing was that
was that whole Dylan Mulvaney Bud Light
Nike sort of thing like is it is it so
bizarre that these big Brands these
these massive Brands like Anheuser-Busch
and Nike like clothing brands are now
obsessed with aligning themselves with
um
biological males that are pretending to
be women
I don't know what do you guys think
about that
is it surprising no
um
I don't know I'm actually surprised to
be honest with you I'm like I'm like why
are they doing this like it
well the same reason any big company
is is doing it the same reason every
June any company you know at least here
in the US within the Fortune 500 or
greater is changing their logo to
rainbows
um you know they don't do that in Saudi
Arabia though like I remember they did a
comparison in June like BMW you know
Boston and BMW you know Saudi Arabia and
the ones in the Middle East stay the
same right they go for the trending
thing don't they
well because it's no longer about money
it's about staying in power and it's
about Executives at these companies that
want to continue to stay in their jobs
and continue making money they have to
pacify the whole crowd so you know if
you're or is it like offshoot people in
the marketing department that have way
too much power that's what I'm like it's
definitely part of it it's definitely
this whole diversity inclusion that's
just become an entire department now and
now it's become you know as important as
marketing and or sales but it's all that
it's you know it's the risk of I can't
remember it was I believe you I don't
remember which I think it was core's a
few years ago you guys remember those
commercials where they'd ran those in
the Super Bowl it was like and they it
was a song like I love Twins or
something like I can't remember exactly
what it was somebody might be able to
pull that and pull that clip but that
was That's How Far We've Come
accordingly like is in the beer company
they ran a commercial yeah and it was
like during the Super Bowl and it was
this guy singing like a song and it was
like you know
I can't remember exactly how the words
went but basically was talking about all
this manly stuff and at the end it was
like oh and I love two blonde Twins and
that's where we went from you might you
may be able to find it on a Quick Clip
but we've gone from that to now we're
about a biological man parading as a
woman in a bathtub
um
uh look like who cares I don't drink
beer much anyway Beer's Bud Light is
swill
um it's garbage beer anyway but
um
I think I found the clip so I'll put it
up on the screen but I'm not gonna run
the audio yeah
um because usually get in trouble with
stuff like that but let me just all that
rolled into one it's no longer about you
know money in my opinion because the
people that are fighting for this kind
of stuff the people that are championing
for all they're not buying beer anyway
like the people that are buying Bud
Light are not these people yeah so it's
not even their target market
so I'll just play it while Bob's talking
but I mean you know you can clearly see
you know what it is that you know he's
talking about here it's it's
you know it's
basically tap you know they used to call
this tap when I was you know younger
stands for tits ass
poon right and you know this is where
they've you know taken it now it's now
gone to you know a place where you've
got some dude that thinks he's a chick
parading around it doesn't make any
sense like
I get that there's people that are that
that might feel like and you just feel
like you know you know quotations
because you guys should know how I feel
about that by now but there's people
that feel like that they should be
something else that they should identify
as a Blackhawk helicopter a a freaking
mole Mouse a woman whatever it happens
to be and historically that's always
been a very very small percentage of the
population probably less than one
percent I don't think there's any other
animal in the in like planet Earth that
goes to the lengths of trying to
identify with something completely
different like humans do and that's fine
you know I don't care I'm a Libertarian
you know do whatever you want but why is
it being crammed in our throat now
everywhere now inclusive of marketing
companies I already know that I'm not
giving these people money right like
Gillette will never see a dime for me
Nike I'm done with I don't drink beer
anyway so screw that [__] right you know
what I mean yeah but but it's not about
being it's not about doing whatever you
want right because that's that's where
we get dangerous like that's when you
put people that are marginal and at risk
actually at more risk you know this is a
conversation I've had with people
actually over the last few weeks where
the whole the hot thing now is to
separate
sex and gender well okay you know then
then fine if if but let's just say if
gender is the only thing if you can
identify however you want if we can we
can cut the link between biological sex
and gender and if that's that's fine but
how we classify things like sports and
locker rooms and bathrooms and spaces
where and jails and prisons we classify
those things by gender not sex so when
somebody who gets convicted for assault
against women sex sexual assault against
women and then during lock up they get
to say actually I identify as a woman so
now I get to go to a woman's prison and
then assault more women it's not about
just do whatever you're getting exactly
what you wanted
let me just chime in here for a second
so um first of all like I'm not a
helicopter but I do identify as the
Blackhawk for sure
um so
of course Blackhawk
um I think there's there's two things in
my opinion that are going on so first of
all like these companies like they have
nothing to lose though okay like the
idea of boycotts doesn't really work
because these companies own so many
brands that if you like drinking beer
you're going to be drinking one of their
products no doubt though so they don't
really have anything to lose like you
know like and in my opinion it is about
money like these companies have
marketing departments that have like
just hundreds of people in it that they
know what they're doing they run the
numbers they know how much they're going
to lose if they've run these campaigns
actually actually that's not true
because I just looked it up here uh
Gillette lost 15 uh quarterly revenue
from that uh toxic masculinity ad so
boycotts to some degree do affect their
bottom line and when you're a publicly
traded company you have a fiduciary duty
to your shareholders so technically at
the end of the day they do have some
effect okay sure um but I guess kind of
the second thing is that the reason why
you're seeing all this nonsense is
because like they're just trying the
market like I think like on average we
know that women make uh 77 cents on a
dollar you know on average if we take
all the professions blah blah blah right
they just dominate the market they
completely dominate the market something
like
um I don't want to say the exact number
but the vast majority of purchases are
controlled by women so yeah even 72 73
yeah so even even if you're buying like
a car like the woman gets a say like
you're not buying the the Mustang you're
buying the SUV or you're buying the the
minivan right because they control
um like you said 70 something percent of
the purchases so
they want to cater to the women in order
to get those dollars like men once they
men don't really care about that kind of
stuff like even the stuff that men spend
money on it's marketing doesn't really
affect that as much like for instance
McLaren doesn't have to advertise their
their cars right their cars are high in
demand and Men buy stuff like that which
marketing doesn't really affect it as
much you know and whereas women they
want to feel inclusive they want to do
all that so like with this campaign
they're just trying to Market to women I
I think I think you hit the nail on the
head and they're
um Mr Canadian because
um Jesse Kelly he's a political pundit
in DC he said the the biggest most
adherent
um demographic to this current insane
walk Marxism gender stuff is the white
liberal Suburban woman and she's the
equivalent of like the you know Mao's
um you know pajama wearing people back
in the Chinese culture Revolution and
Peterson also alluded to it when he said
you know some some and if you look at it
like I got I got black friends that live
in the hood they don't have this problem
because they're too busy trying to keep
their kids safe and put food on the
table and if you look at any of the
proponents of this stuff it's generally
affluent white liberal women and Jordan
Peterson had one example he said you
know the chances of this woman having a
transgender and a gay child under 10 is
5 million to one yeah and I I saw
someone on Twitter say that the the
Coach handbag has been replaced by the
transgender child now yeah dude that's
dude that is that is seriously profound
that is
very astute yeah yeah it's it's that's
where it's coming from man it's just
just what our buddy just said there and
that's marketers targets
um the marketers and advertisers Target
women they get them emotionally and if
you saw that undercover
um real estate thing in New York from a
couple of years ago where this lady
pretended to be a Billionaire's wife
looking for a you know 200 million
dollar pad in New York and she found out
that when Dunes were getting sold these
places they were told about the value of
the investment but every time she went
along it was like imagine your kids here
imagine in this imagine that the
Realtors were selling her imagination
and emotion and that's what they've you
know there is there's affluent white
Suburban women in the Western World I
think they're the next incarnation of
Gandhi and Martin Luther King because
they want you know Tammy to get her
breasts chopped off when she's 12.
yeah it's you know so bizarre because I
you know I saw this meme a couple weeks
ago and I've been thinking about it a
lot because I get you know like anybody
else out there that has a presence I'm
always going to get hate and I always
get hate from these like young nerds
they'll call you names like Boomer or
something like that it's like dude
you know like your generation this and
your generation that it's like yeah at
least my generation didn't cut off its
dick
that I'm like I drop it right now but
this one's affected over here but I
really hope you guys enjoyed that clip
if you want to watch the full length
podcast you can find that over here that
clips from if you're new to the channel
make sure you hit subscribe over here
and pin down below in the top comment
you'll find a bunch of useful links to
my website my supplement line books and
a bunch of other stuff have an amazing
day peace out